what's up brennan what's up theo it's
your boy jake
i told you i wasn't playing around baby
signed a show time
first up t woods gonna give him that
aspirin treatment
that face down ass up same [ __ ]
different day
predicting third round knockout he ain't
quick enough and big enough to take
these hands
i might have to he comes out of my head
throw him in that hard scarf [ __ ] who
knows
but uh out here getting some of that
cross training sweat my ass off
wow what was that floyd yeah
yeah no no problem sir we gotta get back
when this guy's young man anytime you
see an above ground pool they used to
have a lot of men in our area would meet
up they had an abandoned above-ground
pool and people said it was haunted
yeah yeah and a lot of men would meet up
in there and put chairs like uh
he's in a motor home park too as well
would put
um what do those chairs dude that like
the launchers yes lawn chairs in there
and they'd sit there and smoke dope
what a good time get wild i'd do that
right it was like a nightclub kind of
butt in
like in your yard huh oh yeah yeah a lot
of dark [ __ ] goes down there dog
i would do that right now with everybody
in here we should get a above ground
pool
with lawn chips i would we can't why
don't we have any room in here we just
put this thing in here
on the other what we got in the maybe
the other room yeah
i'm impressed by him he's confident he's
confident but he
man look i'm going to say this i i
woodley goes with those
big strike hands i i think he can see
that kind of stuff coming that's what i
just think man
you know really beats him you know
woodley's no i don't think so woodley's
a slight underdog i don't think would
like
he's got more experience than this guy
right as of ufc
fighter woodley hasn't won a round in 20
rounds
he's also mainly a wrestler too though
but yeah we're looking strike
wild card boxing train like movie's the
real deal it's a good fight
that's a good fight need a box or does
he just have those in-game
freaking ball boxes yeah and i'm not i
mean the guy obviously will beat all of
us he would probably have you for lunch
i'm not disputing that look and i think
it'd be he's a big boy though he looked
like your size uh jake no he's not
myself okay
yeah that was actually how uh jake uh
finished his video he said debate club
me or t
wood we had fake paul calling our buddy
no bulldog i'm saying uh you got
i'm gonna say uh jake stevie i don't
know i don't
see i don't know much about that guy uh
nick who you got you're you're educated
i think i'm on jake paul now like i j
woodley's only
sucks dude but i think mentally
woodley's just not there anymore so yeah
yeah
and i think it's jake paul by decision
though that's what i think how many
rounds does it go how many rounds do
they allow
it'll be eight rounds i don't know if
lily's gonna go e-ball
i'm going woodley all the way oh wow
yeah i i'm
when i first found out about the fights
i just went down the rap uh rabbit hole
and started watching like all of his
striking
but you watched the old woodley clips
when he fought you know some of those
older dudes and he has leg kicks than
the threat of a takedown and all the
clips you watched
no there was no leg kicks in them oh
they were all just mainly
boxing yeah here's that overhead left
southpaw yeah
but that's also an older wood that's the
old videos you're watching
you know it's tough to just know what
his what what makes him have a lot of
desire
a nice guy awesome he doesn't look like
he wants to be in there anymore
well i find this fascinating because
it's a it's who knows what's going to
happen
yeah but remember we got that we got on
the same train with the other one when
the man was saying
yeah i didn't think i was going to go
down like that
i think that woodley like you know where
the beef that woodley had with uh
jake paul's uh jake paul's friend corner
man yeah corner man he's a legit boxer i
think it's gonna be
you know how floyd and logan are like
everyone thinks that floyd's gonna go
after logan harder about the whole
gotcha
i think the same mentality is running
through woodley's head like because
he was disrespected by his cornerman
yeah that's fair
is